[Music]
hello and welcome to quadriga Donald
Trump is packing his bags for Asia the
longest trip of his presidency so far it
won't be an easy one even though he does
plan to do some golfing in Japan the
most important stop is China where he'll
encounter his newly exalted counterpart
Xi Jinping the recent Communist Party
Congress wrote the Chinese president's
name and dogma into the Constitution
cementing his status as on a par with
the nation's founding father Mao Zedong
ji is behind a course that has seen
China doubling down on projecting power
economically politically and militarily
and Trump nearly a year after his
election he has little to show in the
way of domestic success and abroad he
risks isolation with his policy of
America first America backs off China
steps in that's the question we posed
today on quadriga and here to answer it
are our guests it's a pleasure to
welcome Gautam and Waka she's an expert
on China and security affairs and she
says she Jinping projects an image of
China as a great power that can offer
the world a new approach to tackle
problems and is ready to take more
international responsibility andreas
couch is editor in chief for handles
Blatt global and he says China's time
horizon is much longer than Donald
Trump's on that scale China is certainly
a rising power while America is
stagnating and that's not a good thing
and a great pleasure to have XI Ming
with us
on the show once again he's a freelance
journalist from China and he says
whether China will become the next
superpower depends how other parts of
the world positioned themselves for
example
Europe and I'd like to start with Yuji
Ming ji is the new strongman of China
apparently but will China emerge
stronger as a result of his policies to
be frank oh we don't know there are very
very contradictory signals coming now
from China of their one hand the economy
is facing a deepening crisis that we see
that the money valves are opened up
since twice three or four years and
still the growth is stagnating on the
other hand the expenses are increasing
very quickly not only for military
purpose but also for insurance purpose
for stabilizing the society for fighting
against economic ecological problems
around from that point of view I am NOT
very sure whether Xi Jinping's policy
they mark to organize the marks but
dominated by state whether this policy
would succeed in that in that sense
would you say that the international
press is overreacting when they say that
GM King is the new Mao Zedong yes a
certainly if which is compared Mao
Zedong in his last two years he was
dying but nobody dares to say anything
against him nobody dares to say anything
against his policy and his henchmen just
stated this that happens instantly we
could also compare Xi Jinping wisdoms
helping do shopping traveled in 1990 to
2000 i anna the man didn't have any
office and any longer and he just gave
two very short interviews and instantly
we experienced a great wave of a reform
and opening-up pro policy but Xi Jinping
had to gather thirteen offices only of
his person but we see that he could not
get through so much not not a part of
them what things your ping could afford
go to wreck some doubts there that we've
just heard about how strong this new
strongman really is your opening
statement says that China that G is
making an effort to project an image of
China as a great power and to offer a
new approach now for years the
international community has been calling
on China to become a stakeholder to
really take responsibility in the
international system would you say it is
now prepared to do that selectively yes
it is but I have to stress selectively
so it's not ready to take over the
position of the United States for
example but I think we see that in the
last five years and the Xi Jinping there
is more self-confidence and more effort
to really contribute to certain global
issues peacekeeping is one of the
examples well China has really stepped
up its profile and where we see that it
becomes more active and it's important
to see that if China talks about
responsible stakeholder it has the right
or thinks it has the right to define
what responsibility means so it will not
just do what the West expected to do
certainly here in Germany at the meeting
of the g20 powers in Hamburg this spring
Xi Jinping was making every effort to
look like the great protector of the
climate treaty just as the US was
deciding that it wants to get out of the
Paris Accord and raise Clute would you
say that this is going to be a bumpy
process this process of adjuncts
adjustment as China rises and America as
you said in your opening statement
stagnates or declines absolutely and
it's first of all it was interesting not
just in Hamburg with respect to climate
change but even before that in Davos
with respect to world trade he's
positioning himself as the successor to
the old American leadership of the world
order which is very fascinating from
China's point of view is of course
incontestable that china is gradually
reclaiming its its historical place as
as world leader they think back to the
Tong dynasty and and beyond and they
think of the last few centuries of
Western
as an aberration but I also know I mean
you said will it be a bumpy ride it'll
be a very bumpy ride and the Chinese
leadership is that's a good thing
aware of this I'm told that the Chinese
leadership has been fascinated for years
by studying periods of history because
usually what you get when one world
power stagnates or declines that another
Rises is unfortunately war and
apparently they're especially interested
in studying the late 19th century when
Germany rose and the British Empire
stagnated and that led to tensions and
eventually war because of course their
whole thing is about peaceful rise about
avoiding that but the bumps will be
there and I'm sure we're going to get to
them can you avoid conflicts of interest
especially when there is someone like
Donald Trump on the other side the other
reason why it's gonna be bumpy and not
entirely a good thing is Chinese rise
does not mean the rise of the values or
ideals that the West is traditionally
stood for even if we've hypocritically
not honored them but at least that we
strive for I think China makes no
pretense at all that this will be a more
democratic or just world ok let's talk
about some of those bumps a year ago
Donald Trump we remember back to the
time just before the election was doing
a lot of China bashing but following his
first meeting with his Chinese
counterpart at his Florida resort home
Donald Trump indicated that the two of
them could become the best of friends at
least some of the time at least he is
now singing Xi Jinping's praises let's
look at how this relationship is
evolving
for Donald Trump the biggest threat to
the US economy is China the meeting will
be a difficult one he tweeted before
Xi's visit in April and complained about
the high trade deficit China warned of a
trade war but at their meeting itself in
Florida there was the appearance of
harmony at the following presidential
insight we had a long discussion already
and so far I have gotten nothing
absolutely friendship I can see that
that meeting both Trump and she were
able to say thanks has Trump learned
from that evening after the party
congress Donald Trump said that Xi
Jinping had emerged as something like
the king of China and he said in the
same interview with Fox News that he
thinks she is a quote very good person
how would you say G Jinping and the
Chinese leadership would be reacting to
these statements from Donald Trump that
are nearly fawning I suppose they are
not going to react say at all because
they know how Donald Trump can be
impractical they know that Donald Trump
is to be very frank a good back for to
say that Donald Trump could play always
pressure very different kinds of
pressures this bashing is one sort of
playing a black male and this this game
was in North Korea with thousand China
see could also regard it as a building
up a huge stage of pressuring China and
then are you saying in other words they
don't trust Donald Trump
no not at all but done
Krum doesn't trust xi jinping either I
don't think so and Andrea's could Donald
Trump said in the interview that I
referred to just now that he has the
best relationship with Xi Jinping of any
president president would you say that
is true and what accounts for this
radical change in tone over the course
of donald trump's president I mean
honestly between his tweets and his
statements this is showmanship I mean
that it means absolutely nothing I think
she Jinping we we often in the West
think that the Chinese have a plan and
everything I do think Qi Jinping will
run circles around this man
intellectually so does uncle Liu Merkel
so do they all I don't think anyone
interpret I mean read zen it takes it
takes any places any currency on Donald
Trump saying we're good friends now
after this meeting so it it III think
they just disregard that and get down to
long-term interest power calculations
both uncle America and Xi Jinping I
think do it that way so Gordon Becker
aside from the overall notion of trust
what kind of relationship do you think
we might see evolve between these two
leaders and also these two countries
certainly one of trumps big issues has
been trade and particularly Chinese
steel since the election campaign he has
talked about possibly putting China into
a punitive duties on Chinese steel so
far it hasn't happened but do you think
the last word has really been spoken no
the last word has not been spoken
because this is one of the topics that
Donald Trump really seems to care about
the unfairness of the of the free trade
agreements that the United States has
signed in the past they have none with
China but there is this huge trade
deficit and so this will remain a topic
I'm sure but there are other topics that
sort of overshadow or take priority over
this also I mean the u.s. at the moment
has its hands full to renegotiate NAFTA
so this will probably keep it busy but
they already introduced punitive customs
on aluminum foil or something like that
so the measures are starting but they're
not really you know it's not a trade war
yet so this will remain structurally so
and also in terms of strategic thinking
the strategic ambition of the other side
I think this is where the major mistrust
between the United States and China
comes from that China doesn't trust the
ambition of the United States there is
always this idea of the u.s. containing
or trying to contain China and its rise
and on the other hand the US doesn't
trust the ambition that China has in the
asia-pacific region speaking of the
asia-pacific region G Ming
one of the ways that the US had intended
to try to contain China was the
trans-pacific trade and investment
agreement TPP Donald Trump's first act
as president was to get out of that
agreement did he in essence hand the
rest of Asia to China by doing so I
don't think it the issue is so plain so
simple we can study China's response
upon Trump quitting TPP many people are
suppose that that China would step in in
the building up for other trade allies
our alliance with the Southeast Asia it
doesn't happen yet and China is not
intended apparently to do that instead
China despite all the Declaration of
protecting a free trade China pursues
something else of China pursued for
example in Europe just one side of the
investment without any fair play for the
protection of investment China shut down
the own
market for European enterprises it is
not just the policy of Xi Jinping but Xi
Jinping continues and I think it is
quite obvious that the United States in
some term just follow China's example
Donald Trump says America first China
doesn't say that but China acts indeed
that's in China first why not Chinese
ambassador to the u.s. said if the USS
America first and we need to protect
ourselves from the trade deficit it's
like looking in a mirror so what you
just said is reflected on the Chinese
side as well and in fact andreas Clute
said to us a little bit earlier that
certainly Donald Trump or that that
China is not going to be looking to play
a values-based leadership role but
that's hardly what Donald Trump is
looking for either his approach to
foreign policy is explicitly
transactional so what would you say he
will be looking for from Xi Jinping in
this meeting in China in terms of
getting a good deal well first of all I
just wanted to briefly also respond to
your previous question about these trade
deals because to me that illustrates I
mean that there are bigger issues North
Korea the South China Sea that we'll get
to but the hit the his response to these
two two trade deals is to me an
illustration of his intellectual failure
and perhaps of the entire group around
him to understand the issue of China's
rise in America's relative decline
because in the trans-pacific free trade
deal he had an opportunity of all the
Pacific regions with America but without
China to tie them together at the same
time he had an opportunity to do the
same thing with the trans Lanting free
trade area to bind the the traditional
West closer together and he said out of
a protectionist impulse totally
misguided no to both allowing China he
could have contained China just in that
that context quite well allowing China
to rise in taking America out of it we
forcing all these other countries
countries to look for leadership
elsewhere so just in that I'll stop
there for now but I just wanted to get
that in and just briefly what would you
say Donald Trump will be looking for a
from Xi Jinping in this meeting I think
he's interested in anything that'll both
with Germany which has a larger trade
surplus towards America than with China
he looks for anything that allows him to
declare victory in that issue they're
exploiting us but selling more to us
than we sell to them a rhetorical point
mainly because he's not going to succeed
and he's going to look he's gonna really
concentrate on North Korea getting the
China to solve this problem and possibly
threat dropping more threats that if
they don't he will solve the problem
which would not be a solution at all and
I think the South China Sea may come up
and I doubt that Taiwan will come up
because I consider that stable so we
talked about what the two leaders might
have in common that transactional
approach but another thing of course is
their willingness and desire to lay
claim to power G misses no opportunity
to reinforce the notion of China's
superpower status and he has thrown to
the wind
the former self-imposed restraint of
Chinese leaders
a show of strength by China to assert
dominance in Asia and the world the
conflict over islands and marine rights
in the South China Sea has been
smoldering for years with both China and
neighboring states laying claim that has
also repeatedly sparked disputes with
the US another showdown is with North
Korea over nuclear weapons
chomp expects XI to send stronger
signals reining in North Korean leader
Kim jong-un China is also expanding
economically investing worldwide the
country is staking its claim in Africa
in the contest over valuable natural
resources China no longer wants to be
the West's factory it wants to drive its
own innovations in addition it's the
largest creditor of the u.s. is China on
its way to becoming the world's new
number one superpower sergey ming
certainly Donald Trump will be looking
to give some kind of message on North
Korea he has repeatedly said he wants to
see China exercise more influence over
North Korea can it and will it I I'm not
sure if China has done too
little steps ahead of this visit of
Donald Trump in Beijing the one is China
has joined more international sanctions
including shutting up o enterprises of
North Korea in China and the other is
China tried to pave the way to set up a
new relationship mm
just to reduce the tensions and so on
and if Donald Trump comes to Beijing T
Jinping might said to them my friend
I've done all what I can or what were
can you demand more I've done would you
expect any of that to make any
difference in North Korea's behavior no
go to and backers speak to North Korea
as well if you like but that's also like
about to ask about the South China Sea
it is rated by many experts as one of
the
most volatile geopolitical hotspots in
the world could we see it become in fact
the site of a hot conflict well hot
conflict it can always spiral out of
control but I think so far we see that
all sides try to sort of keep it you
know within limits actually you could
have expected more after the ruling of
The Hague but because there was a
government change in the Philippines it
made it possible to reopen the door for
a better relationship between the
Philippines and China or North Korea I
think that China will not do more cannot
do more probably because their biggest
priority is that North Korea stays on
the map they don't want an implosion of
North Korea they don't want the millions
of refugees that come with that and they
don't want a reunited Korean Peninsula
with American troops at the Chinese
border that's their priority so on the
South China Sea I think it will depend
on what Donald Trump will say in other
stations of his trip I mean he will go
also to Vietnam to the APEC summit and
it is rumored that there will be a
speech about open and free oceans so it
there will be some announcement of the
on concerning the Indo Pacific and for
the Chinese the word Indo Pacific alone
is a no-go they talk of the Pacific
Ocean and the Indian Ocean but not of
both as a connected thing so I think
there will be some counter movements led
by Japan Australia India and the United
States and so I don't see that the facts
on the ground will change and we're
screwed is it possible that if Donald
Trump doesn't get at least the
appearance of stronger Chinese action on
North Korea that he could turn sour
some people say one of the reasons he's
been making nice is that he has kept on
hoping China might exercise some
leverage
and if this relationship were to go sour
either because of the South China Sea or
because of North Korea what consequences
would that have well I'm sort of
smirking because you asked me if it's
possible that Donald Trump could
unexpectedly turn sour and I think I
mean that's the whole thing about Donald
Trump is the unpredictable and sour is
not even the word he just looked at his
tweets at 2:00 a.m. he the the scary
thing is or by the way it's ironic that
Taiwan which was for many decades the
big issue really appears stable given
that on one side and on the other side
we have these much more dangerous
conflicts and what makes them so
dangerous is that in my opinion cut
China is the only rational actor of all
the ones involved of the three major
ones involved because North Korea well
its problem may be rational but is is is
difficult and now Donald Trump he may
just be faking to be being mad or he may
he may be it and I think it's completely
unpredictable the Chinese side of it was
Goodwin described it very well I think
with Donald Trump at the at the helm on
the other side it's become totally
unpredictable and I think that could
blow up in the South China Sea I think
it is inevitable that long sooner or
later we will in that Chinese what they
consider a Chinese pond the rest of the
world must cannot back down and say
these these are international waters you
cannot build on your Islands permanent
aircraft carriers so that will lead to
conflict and what kind of conflict and
what kind of intentions do you think we
will see from China in regard to the
South China Sea if we look at the party
congress reaming g.z said very strongly
china will defend its interests and
china has been investing heavily in
cutting-edge military technology would
you say china will not back down when it
comes to the South China Sea and could
we then in fact see a conflict arise you
are virtually taking the word
I think the strongest a message of Xian
the last party congresses to make
Chinese army at the top of the world not
just China's economy but China's army
within short time on to so hot conflict
yes or no yes yes yes III suppose even
the military okay
somber closing words thank you very much
for being with us and thanks to all of
you out there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you